♪ ♪
>> WE'LL BE ISSUING DOCUMENT
REQUESTS TO OVER 60 DIFFERENT
PEOPLE AND INDIVIDUALS FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, DONALD TRUMP JR., ALLEN
WEISSELBERG, TO BEGIN
INVESTIGATIONS TO PRESENT THE
CASE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
CORRUPTION, AND ABUSE OF POWER.
>> I COOPERATE ALL THE TIME WITH
EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW THE BEAUTIFUL THING.
NO COLLUSION.
IT'S ALL A HOAX.
IT'S A POLITICAL HOAX.
>> NADLER IS SETTING THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE DEMOCRATS NOT
TO BELIEVE THE MUELLER REPORT.
SAME WE HAVE TO DO OUR OWN
INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: 81 INDIVIDUALS,
AGENCIES, ENTITIES TIED TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP RECEIVED A
FLURRY OF LETTERS TO DEMANDING
DOCUMENTS.
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THEM.
25 OF THE 81 INDIVIDUALS GETTING
THESE LETTERS TODAY FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE UNDER
DEMOCRAT CONTROL.
RANKING MEMBER ON THAT COMMITTEE
AS YOU DO STATEMENT.
"WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THE
MUELLER REPORT SAYS BUT
DEMOCRATS ARE ALREADY HEDGING
THEIR BETS AFTER RECKLESSLY
PREJUDGING THE PRESIDENT FOR
OBSTRUCTION, CHAIRMAN NADLER IS
PURSUING EVIDENCE TO BACK UP HIS
CONCLUSION BECAUSE AS HE ADMITS
WE DON'T HAVE THE FACTS YET."
WE WILL START THERE WITH THE
NEWS OF THE DAY.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
CHRIS STIREWALT, POLITICS EDITOR
AT FOX NEWS.
KATIE PAVLICH, NEWS EDITOR AT
TownHall.com.
JIM MESSINA, DEMOCRATIC
STRATEGIST AND CEO OF THE
MESSINA GROUP.
JIM, WHEN YOU LISTEN TO NADLER
OVER THE WEEKEND ON THE SUNDAY
SHOWS AND HE SAID I'VE REACHED A
CONCLUSION THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND
THEN THE FOLLOW-UP IS WHY NOT
MOVE FORWARD WITH IMPEACHMENT
NOW?
HE SAYS WELL, WE HAVE TO LAY OUT
THE CASE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
IS IT THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE?
>> I THINK IT'S SMART.
DEMOCRATS ARE BEING CAREFUL.
THEY'VE LEARNED SOME LESSONS
FROM THE REPUBLICANS IN THE
'90s WHEN THEY IMPEACHED
PRESIDENT CLINTON.
THEY DON'T WANT TO GO DOWN THAT
ROAD.
THEY WANT TO BUILD A COMPELLING
CASE.
I GOT A BUNCH OF THESE LETTERS
ON MY FIRST DAY, LAWYERS THING
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK INTO THIS
STUFF.
BALANCE OF POWER IN THE HOUSE IS
GOING TO LOOK DEEPLY AT THIS AND
THEY SHOWED.
34 MEMBERS OF PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN OR CLEAR CIRCLE --
CLOSE CIRCLE HAVE BEEN INDICTED.
>> THEY SHOULD HAVE LEARNED
LESSONS ABOUT IMPEACHMENT BUT IT
SEEMS LIKE THE BALL HEAD HAS
BEEN MOVED OFF THE FIELD WHEN IT
COMES TO DEMOCRATS AND WHAT THEY
WANT TO KNOW.
THEY WANT TO KNOW ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
THEN THEY CRITICIZED ANYONE WHO
DARED TO GO AFTER OR QUESTION
THE CREDIBILITY OF ROBERT MILLER
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WHO HE HAD
WORKING WITH HIM.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD CALLS FOR A
WHILE ABOUT PASSING LEGISLATION
LEGISLATION TO PROTECT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS DON'T SEEM TO
BE GETTING WHAT THEY WANT WHEN
IT COMES TO INFORMATION.
THERE'S A PROPER ROLE FOR
CONGRESS WHEN IT COMES TO
OVERSIGHT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT INVESTIGATING
GOVERNMENT SCANDALS LIKE
OPERATION FAST AND FURIOUS WHERE
THE IRS TARGETING CONSERVATIVES.
IT'S ABOUT GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP PERSONALLY USING
CONGRESS AND HOUSE COMMITTEES
WITH SUBPOENAS TO OPEN UP A
TREASURE TROVE OF OPPOSITION
RESEARCH FOR 2020 CANDIDATES.
THE TRUTH IS IMPEACHMENT MIGHT
BE GOOD IN THE PRIMARIES BUT
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE GOOD IN A
GENERAL ELECTION.
>> Bret: THAT'S THE QUESTION.
IT'S A POLITICAL PROCESS.
IT'S NOT A CRIMINAL ENDEAVOR.
LATEST POLLS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
JOB PERFORMANCE, IT'S UP FROM
JANUARY FROM 43 TO 46%.
DISAPPROVAL, 52.
IS THERE A RISK-REWARD MOMENT
FOR DEMOCRATS WHERE THEY HAVE TO
DECIDE, DO WE GO DOWN THIS ROAD
FULLY OR LOOK TO MAKE OUR MARK
LEGISLATIVELY?
>> DON'T UNDER APPRECIATE THE
DEGREE TO WHICH AVOIDING ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN WORK FOR
TRUMP'S FAVOR AND DON'T UNDER
APPRECIATE THE DEGREE TO WHICH
HAVING A FOCUS ON DEMOCRATS, IN
VIRGINIA OR THE GREEN NEW DEAL
OR IT'S NOT BEEN A RUN OF GOOD
WEEKS FOR DEMOCRATS IN TERMS OF
THE NARRATIVE.
I WOULD SAY KEEP A PRAYER AND
KEEP SOME PASSIVITY FOR JERRY
NADLER.
HE'S A SERIOUS PERSON TRYING TO
DO HIS SERIOUS JOB BUT HE HAS ON
HIS COMMITTEE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
BE MORE RADICAL AND AGGRESSIVE
THAN HE IS.
HE IS RIDING A TIGER.
HE NEEDS TO SHOW HIS MEMBERS I
AM ON THE CASE.
WE ARE BEING DILIGENT AND
AGGRESSIVE.
BUT HE WANTS TO KEEP THEM AT BAY
SO THEY DON'T DO WHAT KATIE IS
TALKING ABOUT WHERE YOU HAVE --
NANCY PELOSI AND JERRY NADLER DO
NOT WANT TO IMPEACH TRUMP UNLESS
THEY ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO.
>> Bret: HEARERS JERRY NADLER
ON THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION.
>> THEY CAN BE CRIMES AND
NONIMPEACHABLE OFFENSES AND
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSES THAT ARE
NOT CRIMES.
WE HAVE TO LAY OUT FOR THE ERECT
PEOPLE AND WE CAN'T DEPEND ON
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION FOR
THIS.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION,
NUMBER ONE WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
IT'S ENDING DESPITE LOTS OF
RUMORS.
NUMBER TWO, IS FOCUSED ON
SPECIFIC CRIMES.
>> Bret: DOES IT SOUND TO YOU,
JIM, THAT THEY HAVE A FEELING
THAT MUELLER'S NOT GOING TO
DELIVER WHAT THEY WANT?
>> EVERYONE ON BOTH SIDES IS
DECIDING WHAT THE MUELLER REPORT
IS GOING TO SAY AND IT ISN'T
OUT.
WHEN WE SIT BACK AND LET THE
MUELLER REPORT COME OUT AND THEN
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO NEXT.
THE OBSTRUCTION STUFF, IT'S A
DIFFERENT SET OF QUESTIONS THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO LOOK AT.
>> Bret: WE SAY THAT ALL THE
TIME.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
IT COULD HAPPEN SOON BUT WE
CAN'T PUT A DATE ON IT.
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS GOING ON.
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK.
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS.
>> THERE'S PLENTY WE DO NOT KNOW
AND REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS
SHOULD NOT DECIDE WHAT THEY
THINK IS GOING TO BE IN THE
MUELLER PROBE.
THE PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRATS AS
THEY PUT EVERYTHING ON THIS.
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT RUSSIAN
COLLUSION FOR MONTHS, THAT THERE
WAS EVIDENCE OF THIS WHICH IS
WHY ROBERT MILLER HAD TO BE
PROTECTED.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S INVESTIGATING.
COLLUSION.
THE FACT IS ROBERT MUELLER ISN'T
INVESTIGATING COLLUSION BECAUSE
COLLUSION ISN'T A CRIME UNDER
THE STATUTES HE'S INVESTIGATING.
CONSPIRACY.
PEOPLE ARE USING THE WORD
COLLUSION.
THE TERMS MATTER.
WHEN IT COMES TO SUBPOENAS
ISSUED, IT'S NOT ABOUT
CORRUPTION AND THE GOVERNMENT
AND CORRUPTION IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT'S ABOUT PERSONAL ENTITIES OF
THE PRESIDENTS.
THEY WANT HIS TAX RETURNS.
THEY WANT TO GO AFTER
IVANKA TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP JR.
EVERY SINGLE PERSONAL ISSUE THE
PRESIDENT MAY HAVE THAT THEY CAN
USE ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL
AGAINST HIM TO BEAT HIM IN 2020.
WHEN IT COMES TO THAT LINE, IT'S
GOING TO BE INTERESTING TO SEE
HOW MUCH DEMOCRATS CAN GET DONE
LEGISLATIVELY WHEN ALL THEIR
TIME IS BEING SPENT
INVESTIGATING PERSONAL FINANCES
OF A PRESIDENT THEY SIMPLY DON'T
LIKE.
>> Bret: THERE ARE SOME
INVESTIGATIONS LIKE THE
EMOLUMENTS CLAUSE AND WHETHER
THE PRESIDENT IS USING HIS
OFFICE IN SOME WAY, SHAPE, OR
FORM TO MAKE MONEY, WHERE THEY
INTERSECT, THE PERSONAL AND THE
PRESIDENT.
I WANT TO TURN TO THE EMERGENCY
DECLARATION.
RAND PAUL COMING OUT SAYING HE'S
GOING TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
RESOLUTION.
HE'S GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
RESOLUTION THAT SAYS THEY SHOULD
NOT BE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY
DECLARATION BY THE PRESIDENT.
>> I THINK IT'S EASY TO ARGUE
THAT THIS EMERGENCY ORDER, THIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER GOES AGAINST THE
WILL OF CONGRESS.
NOT ALL CONGRESS BUT THE
MAJORITY OF CONGRESS THAT PASSED
THE APPROPRIATION BILL.
>> I SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT AND WE HAD A GOOD
DISCUSSION.
HE SAYS HE UNDERSTANDS WHERE I'M
COMING FROM AND HE DIDN'T TELL
ME WE WOULD NEVER PLAY GOLF
AGAIN.
IT ISN'T ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S ABOUT THE DIVISION OF POWER
FOR ME.
>> Bret: THERE ARE FOUR
REPUBLICANS SAYING THAT THEY ARE
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT SAYING
THAT THERE SHOULD BE AN
EMERGENCY DECLARED AT THE
BORDER.
THE PROBLEM FOR THEM AND
DEMOCRATS WHO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE IS THAT THE PRESIDENT
HAS THREATENED TO VETO IT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE 67
VOTES.
>> SUITE VAST, RAND PAUL.
SOLID.
NUMBER TWO, IT MATTERS AN
ILLEGAL SENSE BECAUSE AS YOU GO
TO COURT, THE PRESIDENT ASKED
GIVE ME THE MONEY FOR THE THING
I WANT TO.
CONGRESS SAID NO.
AND THEN THEY'RE GOING TO COME
BACK AND SAY WE SPECIFICALLY
DENOUNCE THE ACTIVITY YOU ARE
TAKING.
HE'S GOING TO VETO IT AND HE'S
GOING TO GO AHEAD.
AS THE COURTS LOOK AT IT, IT'S
NOT GOING TO BE AMBIGUOUS WHAT
CONGRESS THINKS.
THE OTHER THING IS THIS IS A
FIRST.
IT WILL BE THE FIRST TIME
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS HAVE
GIVEN TRUMP THE EA.
MITT ROMNEY, BEN SASSE, MIKE LEE